the real forefront of the Corona virus is
now testing, and that's why we're talking
about it, more and more vaccines are a year
away if things go well for widespread use.
Health care workers may have an emergency
use vaccine in the fall if things go perfectly.
We've got dozens of treatments being tested.
Nothing so far has been definitively effective
so that it becomes the standard of care in
terms of existing drugs for off-label usage.
We'll talk a little bit later about the latest
news with hydroxy chloroquine. There is no
magic bullet right now other than social distancing
and widespread testing. Now, the amount of
disinformation and lies from the Trump administration
about testing is staggering. And because testing
is much more opaque than something like deaths,
they are getting away with a lot of these
lies. So which that's why I want to explain
it to you today. So very early on, we were
told we're going to be testing millions and
millions of people per week. We were told
by the end of March we will have 27 million
people tested. It is now nearly the end of
April. And we have only tested four million
people. OK. We're a month past when they said
we would have tested 27 million. We've only
tested four million people. The numbers are
public. They're release daily. You can find
them at Cauvin tracking dot com. Now, Donald
Trump is insisting that we have the best tests
and we are doing the most testing. Now, neither
is true. We're dealing with possible combinations
of both false, positive and false negatives
with tests. Anecdotally, but more importantly,
in terms of per capita, we've done about 12000
tests per million people in the United States.
That puts us 40 second in the world in per
capita testing. Now, there will be people
who will say, come on, David, you're you know,
we're 40 second if you include the Pharaoh
Islands and Gibraltar as countries. They are
tiny. They shouldn't really be part of the
equation. Fine. If you take out the tiny countries,
right. If you don't include the Channel Islands,
if you don't include Aruba, we are still only
twenty eighth in the world in per capita testing.
So the reopening guidelines say that to even
move to phase one, states must have, quote,
the ability to quickly set up safe and efficient
screening and testing sites for symptomatic
individuals and trace contacts of coded positive
results. The ability to test syndrome IC and
influenza like illness indicated persons for
coronavirus as well as the trace contacts
of those individuals and sentinel surveillance
sites that are screening for asymptomatic
cases and contacts for people positive for
coronavirus. In practice, no state has that
right now. But notice that there are no metrics
there. There are no metrics for the number
of tests. If they came out and said states
must be able to test 2 percent of their population
on a daily basis. OK. And must be doing so
in order to move on to phase one. Now we're
talking. Now we have something tangible to
talk about. The real single important question
right now is when will actual tests completed
increase? Because they won't tell us this.
On Monday when this was asked, Dr. Bourke's
put up a picture, put up a graph of labs that
can process tests. That doesn't tell us the
number of tests that we must be doing and
when we will be able to do them. Testing centers
don't mean much if they're not processing
tests, how many tests are we doing? How many
tests can we do and do we need to be doing
in order to move on to phase one? Sometimes
the Trump administration will say there are
enough tests out there to double capacity.
Capacity doesn't mean that the tests can actually
be done. It means the materials for the tests
are out there. But we need to actually be
processing tests. Trump regularly talks about
tests like exciting new iPhones. Take a look.
Say an incredible test. Score the idea. Now,
point of care, diagnostic test. And it's fantastic.
So it's not one problem with this business
is it's hot until about two days from now.
Because we do have a saliva test that just
came out and that can be self-administered.
And it's said to be fantastic.
Yeah, lots of exciting new products for Corona
virus customers. Yet the one number that matters,
which is tests being done, is not going up.
This is not a secret. Cauvin tracking dot.com
tells you each day how many tests are being
done. And as you can see, we're telling where
we put the numbers up on the screen all the
way from the start of April, which is what
we're looking at. The tests per day are basically
unchanged. We are testing between 120 and
160000 people a day. Trump recently claimed
tests. Done are doubling weekly. They aren't.
Here's the data I'm showing it to you. And
in the meantime, we had a record number of
deaths in the United States yesterday. So
very clearly we're not ready to reopen. I
want to reopen as badly as everybody. I'm
sick of being home of the life we lived in
January. Seems so foreign at this point, but
we're just not there. And if the 1918 flu
pandemic tells us anything, it's that if you
open prematurely, you are worse off in the
medium and long term. It's painful to remain
closed. I get it. But we are simply not ready
when we reach @s a new high and deaths yesterday
and we have not increased the actual tests
done.
Remember, capacity is a code word for B.S.
Tests done have not increased during the month
of April. We're simply not ready. You disagree
with me by missing something? Let me know.
I'm on twitter at Deepak's The David Pakman
Show